you're now starring in this superhero
series it's DC star girl are you did you
grow up a comic book guy I mean I was
really a Mad Magazine guy that was like
the first thing I remember really
getting organized to do was to get a
subscription to Mad we're okay I got to
put 12 bucks together and and fill out
the form and and so yeah I was really in
demand I was watching him I got a damn
ad was great and if you're and if you're
in a bind yeah you read Kraft did you
ever get to that position that cracked
was like okay I've read this Mad
Magazine like five times so alright I'll
go and take a look at the cracked I
won't buy it but all right to get out of
the kiosk and look at it yeah I really
did have fun getting into the superhero
world I mean it was it was I did have
trouble like there's so many characters
like you know villains and supervillains
and villains that used to be good and
bad like when we were doing the show
Breck Basinger in place my stepdaughter
our star girl and she was great actress
and such I went into the project thing
I'm going to kind of teach these kids
how it's done hopefully I'll get to show
them some of the things I've learned
from some of these great actors over the
years you'll be like Brando in The
Godfather high-teens happening Pacino
and Duvall you know you'll be showing
them the ropes that's really how I
thought it was going to be and then I
got there and then all these kids are
such pros I mean really nice kids but
also so well organized and they you know
Breck for instance you know she knew not
only her dialogue but my dialogue so I'd
get kind of mixed up with these
superheroes and we'd be doing a scene
and that said okay look we've got to get
to Iceman Slayer right now and she'd say
what about icicle and I'd say look we
got to get to icicles wouldn't even they
wouldn't even cut and you know they're
you know there'd be scenes where we'd
finish doing something and I'd have to
go up to
breck and say look I'm sorry I I always
get Johnny Thunder and Hawkman mix for
some reason they sound the same to me
and she'd say no that's okay I've just
got to go do some strut stunt training
for three hours Luke so that's great but
yeah sometimes I get a little mixed up
and the the DC Comics superhero lore and
the names is it true that you you have a
little bit of a reputation on set for
maybe sometimes going into your dialogue
a little early no my my the kid playing
my son trailer man oh this really funny
great kid I overheard him saying one day
to Brack like yeah you got to be really
careful with Luke don't take a pause
because then he'll just start talking
and I said hey by the way I don't know
your dialogue I just don't know mine so
if I see you stop talking I'm gonna
start in on my dialogue so you got to be
quicker off the trigger and then I tried
to just kind of turn it into a thing and
remember this is the DC Universe think
you guys are moving fast
ya know we gotta have that it's like a
lot of action so you got to be ready but
then you know you look around and
there's the crew watching you having
this kind of argument with the 12 year
old and but no Trey Trey Trey is one of
my good friends but he did complain how
he couldn't take a pause and I said hey
buddy I'm just telling you right now I
see you like look out the window or look
down at the ground I'm coming in hot
with my either gift or kid the word
seems where he'd be just doing this kind
of rapid-fire dialogue you know you got
to watch it because for years we've been
doing shows at Comic Con and those
people take this universe or any
universe very seriously and if you're
playing a character and they run into
you they expect you to know everything
about this DC universe believe me I've
had to like watch myself I've had people
come up and say hey I hear you're in
star girl on said yeah it's it's a it's
a really great show and then the guys
say well you know this
brain wave is she ever gonna do battle
with our class and I'll say I'm not
quite sure like I'll see it in their
eyes that they know that I don't know
what I'm talking about completely
uncomfortable but you know it would be
like saying like yeah I'm a Yankees fan
and then someone say like do you like
Derek Jeter and said who's there Jeter
my best to get better but yeah I really
try and keep those conversations very
brief and say you know just do the thing
hey I don't want to spoil anything for
you about the show you'll just have to
watch my advise to you Luke is shoot
your scenes and then get back to the
bungalow as quickly as possible don't
wander around if someone might ask you a
question okay that's when ghosts on the
set